let's say we have two people in
identical jobs person a
and person b and this past year they
both got paid in their identical jobs
they got paid 350 000
in salary
now let's assume that person a has no
deduction so they just calculate their
taxes and for the sake of simplicity i'm
just going to make up a number i'm not
going to go through of it and especially
because the tax code changes every year
let's just say their regular taxes are
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
one hundred and fifty thousand
in regular taxes
regular taxes when you just file taxes
the straight well not the
straightforward but just the regular way
let's say person b on the other hand
even though they have the exact same job
they donate a bunch to charity they have
all of these deductions they have all of
these things that they can write off
from their income and so person b's
taxable income
let's say that it goes down with all of
these deductions the taxable income goes
down to two hundred thousand dollars
and on that taxable income of two
hundred thousand dollars person b has to
pay seventy thousand dollars in regular
taxes
and once again i'm just making up simple
numbers just so that uh just for the
sake of simplicity i'm not actually
figuring out exactly what person v's
taxes are seventy thousand in regular
taxes
now the u.s government or the irs says
hey look person b actually made a lot of
money made a similar amount of money to
person a they did all of these
deductions allowed them to pay a lot
less a lot less in taxes we don't
necessarily like that this person's
making a lot of money we think that they
should
pay some alternative minimum tax and the
way that's calculated is for either
party there's this completely separate
tax code so alternative
minimum tax
and so you calculate your regular taxes
so that's this number and this number
and then in parallel you calculated an
alternative minimum tax and in the case
of either of these people what happens
is that you don't get most of these
deductions right here that's really done
basically for simplicity purposes on
your on your gross income
and it's a much simpler tax code it's
almost a flat tax at the 350 000 level
you get no standard deduction and it's
really it's 26 percent right now on the
first 175 000 and then it is 28 on the
next 175 000 if you're making this much
money it's a little you have a deduction
if you make less than that and all the
rest i won't go into the details but the
general idea is you calculate this for
either party and in either situation the
alternative minimum tax for either of
these people is going to be ninety four
thousand five hundred dollars ninety
four thousand five hundred dollars
so this guy person a will calculate his
amt he gets ninety four thousand five
hundred dollars he's like well my
regular taxes are 150 000
so i pay the higher of the two he pays
his regular taxes this is just done just
to make sure that his amt isn't higher
person b on the other hand his regular
taxes after all of his deductions came
out to seventy thousand dollars so he
has to pay the amt because the amt is
higher than his regular taxes so this is
what he pays so the general idea you
compute your regular taxes you compute
the amt two separate tax codes you pay
the higher of the two and the whole idea
of this is to make sure that people who
have a certain income aren't able to
deduct it all away and pay a very very
low income tax